gérald gallant tué de sang froid il a
reconnu avoir éliminé 28 personnes
pourtant en apparence il avait l'air
d'un homme banal
et si cet aspect qui a d'abord fait
signer le picard hilton musique hip hop
menaçant quand tu le rencontres mais en
même temps c'est un des tueurs à gage de
plus prolifique de l'histoire du québec
et c'est pas juste la quantité de gens
que tu es 28 c'est la façon qu'ils le fk
l'hypnose et c'est très froid très
méthodique il était le tueur attitré du
rock machine lors de la guerre des
motards dans les années 90 ses victimes
surtout des membres du crime organisé
c'est rare qu'on a des personnages aussi
fantaisiste aussi colorés ou si fou
aussi dérangé parce que ce sont des gens
qui font des meurtres pour des pinottes
le 5 10 mai 9h ils vont faire des
meubles au risque de passer leur vie en
prison
gérald gallant un homme complexe et
mystérieux même pour son épouse
c'est un bon mari qui se prenait soin
d'elle à sa façon pirate et était un peu
naïve qui est fascinant aussi c'est que
dia lança pour être notre voisin cette
histoire leur parle d'un meurtrier
québécois qui avait l'air de rien pour
certains de ces assassinats
gallant a pu compter sur la complicité
de sa maîtresse c'est de l'amour salle
mais beau plein d'espoir bonnie and
clyde un peu quitte animé par le goût de
l'aventuré delà du côté noir la personne
où il ya quelque chose de bonnie and
clyde
durant des années l'homme a échappé à la
justice ironie du sort c'est pour une
histoire de fraude qu'il a été arrêté en
2006 il a alors décidé de passer aux
aveux et de devenir délateur
en 2009 il a été condamné à la prison à
perpétuité sans possibilité de
libération conditionnelle avant 25 ans
le tournage au québec qui se termine
demain
gérald gallant été arrêtés en europe
l'équipe se déplacera du côté de
bruxelles pourrait créer cette scène le
film prendra l'affiché sur nos écrans en
2020 s'il est bien alexandre chartier
radio-canada cinq ans